okay
ladies and gentlemen members we are now
live it is six o'clock so we will get
underway good evening and
welcome back to the council chamber for
our first
uh in-person live meeting um as you
members know but members of the public
my name is councillor peter richards and
i'll be sharing this evening's meeting
um we've got a few bits and pieces to go
through first if i
may first of all members could you
please make sure and support you
please make sure your phones are turned
to silent preferably off but silence
fine
and we don't want to disturb any this
evening's proceedings
um you will notice the proceedings for
the committee are detailed on
uh page two i think of our agenda packs
you are all well versed in that so i
won't go through them all now but just
to remind you that
is where they are for members of the
public this is
um this is a meeting that is being held
in public it is not a public meeting
so only those people that have
registered to speak will be asked
to speak i will call you forward at the
appropriate time please keep your masks
on
when you come up to the table the table
is just to my right here to the members
of public it's your left
when you sit down please would you use
the anti-back
uh squeegee thing there to do your hands
and when you have finished
if you could use one of the wipes that
are on the other side of the desk
just give the desk a quick wipe down um
the
microphone buttons and also the arms of
the chair ready for the next person that
would be greatly appreciated
okay uh let me just get my papers in the
right place
um we do i do have
one very sad announcement um
unfortunately um
uh at the weekend a um the next
counselor councillor chris williams
sadly passed away on saturday um council
williams was a member of this council
for 21
years for various awards he was also a
county council member
i've known him since i was elected he is
and always has been a very very good
man uh in my opinion um
his his wife carol has been through a
lot supporting him
um and i think it would be fitting for
us to have a minute silence
for chris but also to give our thoughts
to carol as well
a very sad time so if we could please
bow our heads and take one minute
thank you very much everybody i
appreciate that okay let's dive
in to our meeting just to remind
everyone again um we are being live
streamed and we are being recorded so
um this will be available on the uh
council's website in due course and also
on youtube um first of all if we could
have apologies
for absence please chair we have
apologies from councillors dixon
eden and hunter serafin thank you very
much and members any disclosures of
interest please if you could show your
hands
none on the last item i am enlisted as
war member i'm indeed the war member
um i'm here in open with an open mind so
i will remain on the committee for
that item um minutes is our next item is
everyone happy with the minutes as i
presented in
the agenda pack if you are i will sign
them all afterwards there's lots of
nodding
everyone happy okay terrific i shall do
that
uh shortly okay um
one last quick thanks to councillor
parry you will notice she is not here
with us tonight
sadly councillor perry is no longer on
the committee she's still uh here at the
council and is
taking up a much more detailed role with
the cabinet so we wish her well and
thank her for the contribution she's
made
to date okay
uh to introduce all of our uh officers
as well if i may so to my left we have
our solicitor mason nash
to my right we have committee services
olivia quinn
uh we have a number of officers uh
planning officers with us so first of
all shirt flairtyo is sat here
we will be joined later on by joe brook
and we also have
david jeffery who is our planning
manager david i believe you have a
statement you'd like to make
i do thank you chair good evening my
name is david jeffrey i am the committee
manager for tonight
my role is to provide impartial advice
to clarify
planning issues that arise and to assist
members in their decision taking
planning committee members are not bound
by advice from officers
or by their recommendations thank you
chair
thank you very much okay so our first
application is application twenty zero
three zero five four fuel that is
mappleburg green
you will notice members that there are
no registered speakers which means we
can move to delegate so if i could
please have a show of hands those
that are happy to delegate that is
unanimous so we will do that
and move on to our next item which is
once again being presented by shirt
flairty this is
land adjacent to oakfield uh miller's
close in welford on ivan
stewart when you're ready over to you
thank you chairman good evening
everybody um this proposal is seeking
full planning permission for the
erection of two dwellings and its
associated works
uh the application site is within the
adopted bilterberry boundary of welford
on avon
signified by this black dots on the plan
here is a plan denoting the location of
the site
with the red boundary you
also see here the purple line which
denotes
the conservation area boundary uh the
two dwellings proposed
are entirely outside of that boundary
but are clearly
immediately butting that boundary there
are also then some listed buildings here
signified
in red in the wider vicinity
uh here we just have an aerial satellite
imagery just showing
the wider character of the area
signified by the red arrow
here um here is the submitted
uh proposed site layout plan um showing
the
two dwellings um there is um
[Music]
uh front parking accessed off millis
close
here we have some elevational detail
there are a series of dotted lines
on this imagery on your screens this
didn't prepared by the applicant this
denotes
previous iterations and previous designs
of other applications on this site
here we have a proposed street scene
plan um just detailing the how the two
proposed dwellings would sit
in the main frontage one one is stood on
mill is close
now we have some uh photos of the site
uh we're looking eastward here
um towards a neighboring property um
here
um and we can see there is currently
what is a vacant plot
uh grass area um
again more imagery showing similar uh
details now we're just looking northward
you can see the north boundary here
some wider properties in the in the
wider vicinity
and now we're looking uh westwards um
we can see uh immediate neighboring
properties here
um modest bungalows and the wider sort
of snapshots of the area
finally here's just a close-up picture
of a
similarly neighboring property this is
on the opposite side of the application
site
positive and proactive discussions have
taken place between the uh
applicant local conferences in the
district to attempt to find an
acceptable solution for this site
um officers are of view that an
accessible solution has now been found
uh delivering two family homes in what
is defined to be a sustainable location
and consider to be what is a coherent
logical space for residential
development
um chair there are no updates to to
report
uh the recommendation is one of grant uh
subject to conditions
uh for the reasons that page 34 of your
gender pack thank you
fabulous thank you very much indeed
let's move to our first speaker we have
a counselor neil
appleton from welford parish council
good evening councillor if you'd like to
make your way forward if you could
please anti-back your hands
and once you're seated you can remove
your mask
fabulous thank you very much and welcome
good evening um
the button in the middle of your uh of
your microphone we'll turn it on and
when you're ready speak if you would
please press that a light will show you
can see on mine here it turns red
uh you'll have three minutes and if you
could say seated for questions
afterwards that'd be great we'll give
you a 30 second warning
when your time is approaching the end
whenever you're ready feel free to start
good evening councillors the parish
council submitted its objection to the
development of two homes on miller's
close
on the 2nd of march in summary our
objection was based
on two main points first the bulk and
mass of the proposed development
and second welfare donation has far
exceeded its quota of new homes
the applicant has modified a proposal
following the consultation period to
reduce the bulk and mass by reducing the
ridge height and including hip roofs
this is closer to what we consider
acceptable and i will discuss this
aspect no more
on housing numbers we estimate to date
there are plans approved for
approximately 192
new dwellings within welford on avon in
november 2016
there were only 115 that was in the
welford neighborhood development plan
on the 31st of march 2020 stratford
district council calculated 131 and the
parishes
council's own records from april 2020
indicate 167.
between april and december of last year
plans were approved for another 25 homes
in short there is an ongoing
unsustainable increase in the number of
homes within welfare on avon
it far exceeds the upper limit specified
in cs16
and shows no sign of slowing down this
is skewing development across the
district
a very few lsv's are taking the lion's
share of the development
this is contrary to the principle of
balanced dispersal upon which
sdc planning policy is based and is
central to cs16 of the core strategy
on the face of it hlu1 allows a small
in-field development and would appear to
apply in this case
this is what the case officer uses to
override cs16
however other policy points must be
adhered to and this is stated explicitly
in hlu1
in other words hlu1 should not be used
to justify approval
if it undermines the core principles of
strategic planning
policy however this is precisely what is
happening
over the last 10 years we have seen
creeping development within welfare on
avon
which was neither foreseen nor is it
desirable
the recent publication of the site
allocations plan supports this view
i refer to section 2213 it identifies
it identifies tranches as a reserve land
to be released for development
it states that a number of lsvs have
already significantly
i.e more than 20 percent exceeded the
indica
indicative housing numbers set out in
core strategies cs16
in this document the council clearly
acknowledges
that some villages have suffered
sustained excessive development
and defines a benchmark for what is
considered significantly
excessive welford has exceeded
the indicative housing numbers in cs16
by more than 100
therefore it clearly falls within the
category of having significantly
exceeded its indicative housing numbers
this policy point must therefore be
adhered to
that is the view of welfare donation
parish council we urge
council members to support this view and
uphold our objection to this planning
application
thank you for your time that was dead on
three minutes
thank you very much well done members do
you have any questions
for council mills first thanks very much
um
did you um have any consul or did the
parish council have any consultation
with the developer at all on this
they did counsel sorry when you're
responding to questions you wouldn't
thank you so much sorry very much
right yes um i believe so um
and there was a lot of discussion around
the the bulk of the mass
and i believe the developer has
responded to
our concerns and they have removed
reduced the volatility they have reduced
yeah they have um
i mean our preference would have been a
slightly different scheme but
um they have would have been what what
we would have preferred i believe
um a house in a bungalow i think that
was the uh our
case right thank you but that's not
withstanding the housing number
issue thank you thank you very much both
do we have any further questions council
crown please
just going back on that i'm playing
devil's up advocate
um i assume you would have preferred no
houses rather than the house and bongo
in the first place but
um because you're obviously saying that
you've far exceeded the
the indicative numbers in yeah so i was
just just kind of behind that point
so your preferred option wouldn't if you
had to have it would have been a house
in the bungalow
um but your main point is that you far
exceeded the numbers in the uh
strategy absolutely yes that's that's
the primary
objection yes and the balkan well the
bulk and mass
i mean we would probably be prepared to
accept what's been proposed
okay at our last meeting we felt that
what was proposed was acceptable on
balance
brilliant thank you very much thank you
councillor adam please
thank you um i just noticed a slight
discrepancy between
um your numbers and the the officers
numbers in the report
can you just let me know where you got
your numbers for the housing
in welford please right um will we keep
an ongoing tally um
of the numbers in welford um i've got
the map actually from 2020 december
2020. i've got the one from april
um i can i can show it to you if that's
allowable i don't know
unfortunately things have to be
submitted before yeah when you
appreciate that because i'm i'm gonna
have to say no
i'm fairly new to that um it's something
that um we as a
parish council keep an ongoing tally of
um and i'm
also aware of that discrepancy i thought
there was quite a big difference between
the number 131 and 167 i thought that
was quite a big
so um yeah i think that highlights uh
an issue in my view thanks very much
thank you
members unless there are any other
questions we will move on
in that case counselor thank you very
much if you wouldn't mind turning the
microphone off and then if you could
give it a quick wipe with one of the
anti-bacterials and the table as well
that would be
greatly appreciated
hmm thank you very much appreciate it
thank you
um okay our next speaker then is mr
elliot goodall
uh do we have mr goodall good evening
welcome
so once again if you wouldn't mind
anti-backing it's going to get quite
repetitive this i'm afraid everybody we
are going to hand you back every time we
have a speaker and we have quite a few
and as soon as you're ready to sit down
and feel free to take off your mask now
that you are sat down um so mr google
same rules apply so you have uh three
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning if you can stay seated
afterwards uh for any questions that
would be great otherwise whenever you're
ready if you press the middle button
and you're good to go
agent styling varies in miller's close
but the main character is
of pairs of dwellings that mirror each
other built in either brick or with
rendered facades and tiled roofs
in the main roofs are hipped and the
houses are set back from the road
with parking in front many particularly
those in the immediate context
are further adorned with a single story
lean to outshot to the side ext to the
side elevation
there are 28 two-story houses and only
seven bungalows on this close as
demonstrated by the wider street scenes
submitted
the two dwellings have been designed in
response to the predominant character
they represent a merit pair are
constructed from red brick with a hipped
tiled roof they have a single story lean
to out shot
structure on the outside elevation and
are set back from the road
consistently the proposals for this site
have evolved over time
taking account of comments from the
parish council the ward member
and neighbours such as reductions in
height and styling
plus the prescription of dark sky policy
lighting
for reference the parish council
supported the previous application
on design grounds which was a taller
scheme
objection from ward member and pc was
raised against the current submission on
the base that the proposals were too
dominant
with height being the pertinent issue
this scheme
before you is reduced over the previous
refusal
on reflection of the comments subsequent
adjustments have been made
upon the advice of the planning officer
to attempt to lessen the scale further
the rooves were amended from gable to
hit roofs to provide a gradual reduction
in scale from the centre of the site to
the edges
reducing the visible impact on the
adjacent properties
these changes respond positively to the
consultant's objections regarding design
and comments raised by neighbours the pc
was reconsulted
by the officer and the chair has
admitted verbally that the design
is now of no longer a concern
the objection has been maintained and he
has confirmed my presumption that this
was on the grounds of housing numbers
the site and the proposed development is
deemed to satisfy the criteria for being
a small scale development
as described in policy as 10. being of
small scale
and on on an infill plot the development
is considered
by the officer to satisfy the
requirements policies cs15 and 16 and
the ndp notwithstanding the over
provision in welford
for information the applicant is
directly involved in the delivery at
least two bungalows within the village
with the provision of two three-bed
houses the proposals
uh the applicant is delivering a mix
that specifically satisfies the welfare
ndp
the views of the site from the
surrounding open countryside is limited
as noted in the landscape sensitivity
assessment for welford
um the site is or the landscape is
referred to as being of medium
sensitivity which is the lowest
classification of land surrounding
wildford
in addition the report goes on to note
that the designation comes from land's
biodiversity value not from
intervisibility
um that is your that is your three
minutes i'm afraid
um if you want to wrap up with one last
sentence you can just
say we we have made some um
significant proposals regarding
biodiversity which i hope are
seen as positive perfect wrapping up
thank you very much
members do you have any questions for mr
goodall counselor adam
it's just um quickly did you um make an
assessment of housing need
within the village in the area we have
it now
okay thank you anyone else
no in that case thank you very much
again if you wouldn't mind just giving
the desk a quick wipe down
um i should have said before if you can
please fix your masks back
on you when you uh when you're not sat
at your desks for members of the public
you don't need to wear one while you're
sat down unless you want to
but as soon as you get up from your
chair if you would please refit your
mask that i'd be grateful
thank you
fabulous thank you very much so our next
speaker can spare together
once again if you could anti-back
i think you know the drill by now so
you'll have five minutes we'll give you
a 30 second warning
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start
okay um good evening committee members
um so while the height of the dwellings
have been reduced since the last three
applications
and also following an appeal which was
dismissed
the proposed development is still
dominant in relation to other properties
in miller's clause
in particular to the row of bungalows
and therefore
it will still impact on neighboring
residents as well as on the miller's
close-on setting
hlu-6 of the neighborhood development
plan
states the development of the village
edge will be of a similar density and
scale to buildings in the immediate
neighborhood the officers
recognizes in his report that there is
conflict
with spd guidance in not achieving a
desired garden depth of 10 meters
this implies that the development
footprint
is too large for its plot
there is also an ft biodiversity loss
and in light of the climate emergency
the council should be ambitious
and move away from biodiversity of
setting to biodiversity net gain
as it stands the proposed development
fails to demonstrate
a biodiversity net gain and biodiversity
is not just
about protected species
it is also about enabling local wildlife
to inflow and
full and flooring trees to thrive but
most importantly i do not agree with the
planning officers housing numbers
interpretation
core strategy policies 15 refers to
distribution of development
states that the distribution of
development in stratfor don't even
district during the planned period
2011 2031 will be based on a pattern of
balance
dispersal and core strategy policy 16
housing development specifies that in
category two villages such as welford
no more than around 12 percent should be
provided in an individual settlement
this equals to around 84 houses
as we heard in the past few years well
for the seen a large increase
in development as per december 2020
from our own calculations there have
been 192 dwellings approved
with 142 i think in the build-up area
this is exceedingly more than doubling
the required 84 houses
calculated in the course strategy
welford has done its bit
and we can't go on in filling every bit
of green left in the village
indeed this is a point that has been
confirmed in the preferred options site
allocation plan
in relation to the position of welford
the village has been placed in tier vii
for release of sites tier vii is for
those local service villages that have
already accommodated significant
housing we have now reached quite a lot
of in-field development and there must
be a limit
in particular as the village's serious
infrastructure problems
caused by this over-development the ndp
policy infrastructure 2
enf 2 states that any development
proposal could have a detriment
that could have a detrimental effect on
infrastructure services including
drainage
will be resisted unless it is fully
supported by an implemented mitigation
scheme and while the site is located
within flood
flood zone 1 the village including its
flood zones 1 is increasingly vulnerable
to
pluvial and sewage flooding as we have a
combined system which was built for a
much smaller settlement
indeed we had we had suffer sewage
incidents
on on roads and unfortunately in private
gardens
and even inside homes another serious
incident happened in florida
flood zone 1 in another relatively new
development in the village last october
and i have not seen any evidence that
the serious infrastructure problems with
sewage capacity in welfare
have been satisfactory solved from both
the local flood authority and from seven
trend
is unsustainable to keep approving new
housing even smalling field developments
without upgrading our infrastructure
i def either for respectfully ask that
this application
is refused council as well within your
time thank you very much members do we
have any questions we can suppose
together cancer mills please
um does this land flood
is it flooded in the past
i'm not sure but we had um other
incidents of surface water runoff
and sewage flooding in other flooded
zones
but not on this particular piece of land
not that i know
not that i'm aware of but it might be
okay yeah
thank you anyone else have a question
before i have a go
no casper kelly you mentioned tier vii
you went through it so quick i didn't
catch it could you
tell me again what you were saying about
tier 7 yes so in this
in the preferred options of the psycho
location plan
which had gone to a public consultation
uh welford
has been placed for release of our
reserve housing sites in tier seven
and tier seven is uh for those local
villages
uh that have already accommodated
significant housing so the stratfor
district council itself
recognizes the over-development that has
happened in welford
understood thank you very much okay
councillor curtis next week
thank you chair manuela and
just picking up this um point that you
make about the
infrastructure being upgraded yes i mean
i'm aware there's been a lot
of new development in welford
and has there been then a general
upgrading of
particularly the the sewage
infrastructure or is it still very much
reliant on what was there 10 years ago
well the so what they do with new
developments
of you know kind of larger developments
so that they put like a
sewage pump so now of all developments
of a certain
um you know number of dwellings they
they
they have to have a sewage pump that
then would pump
the sewage in the night onto the main
system so this
is because our current system can't uh
can't cope
um and so we already have that we have
had
meetings with the parish council last
october when
this other incident happened in a home
um with uh seven trent i had
uh meetings with uh uh
i remember the but there was another
accident two years ago
where sewage enter houses and we had
other meetings with
um council personnel i think you've
answered the question now whilst i'd
love to listen to you talk for hours i
think we probably need to move on i'll
see you again
thank you yeah council crump please
thank you mr chairman um yeah i'm
supposed to get um obviously it must be
very distressing to
to either be flooded with water or even
less research and
and you may well know i've got flooding
at the candy council so i'll fully
empathize with that whatsoever and it
seemed that the main thrust
the objection from the parish council
related to the housing numbers
um it's quite noticeable they didn't
actually mention the infrastructure they
didn't actually mention flooding
in their presentation um so whilst i can
see
it's it's it is of concern it wasn't the
main concern
of the parish council so i'm just
wondered
they got three minutes i know but if it
if it was that
give it sorry sorry to cut across you um
i feel a little bit like you're debating
rather than asking a question if you
could ask a clear question for me that
would be really appreciated
okay i'll try and rephrase um
can you um enlighten me with
why you concentrated on on the flooding
issue
in in which is was different to the the
minor thrust of the argument from the
parish council
who weren't rising concerned about no no
it's um so
in my i i'm actually quite very uh
i was very precise it's the housing
numbers and the infrastructure
uh the problems that we're having it's a
cause of these over development
so i can also talk about our highway
infrastructure
and our school i think we'll leave that
for another day if i'm honest
um i think infrastructure covers the lot
okay unless there are other questions
um i think we'll probably move on no
okay cancer first get it thank you very
much again if you wouldn't mind
giving the table a quick wipe on the
chair as well the chairs arms uh we will
carry on while you do that if that's
okay
um okay so members uh our next port of
call is to ask any points of
clarification to our officers
do you want to dive in counselor adam
first please
thanks uh two um things i was going to
ask
first was the housing numbers which um
there seems to be a discrepancy
between what's in the report and what's
being picked up by the ward member and
uh the parish council there you go on
that one first
thank you councillor um yes the the
figures quoted in your agenda packs
are based on the data that we as
officers have to go on um they're
probably displayed on our stratford
district policy website those housing
figures and a breakdown by settlement
are there um to the best of my knowledge
um and my senior colleague has just
verified this on on the screen as well
um these are the latest figures that we
as officers have to go on
um if i understand that the parish
mentioned
they had more up-to-date figures within
their own studies um
these are district figures that we have
to go on as officers
so is there room within that to accept
that the the numbers from the parish may
be correct even though it's not included
in the report
i didn't have enough evidence in front
of them i'm afraid to verify or
or at this stage of this evening but um
these figures are the latest ones that i
have to go on and that's reflected in
the report
thank you for that um bear with me just
moment please cancer island schools
while we're on the numbers it makes
sense to ask this question
it had the numbers that were presented
by the parish council been the numbers
in your pack would it have materially
changed your decision
or your report um i appreciate that
i can't speculate too much on on on what
had what may be different
um what i would say um i was going to
comment to this as well i guess but on
page 29 of your agenda pack so i have
addressed the housing numbers
i hope i'm happy to to field further
questions on them
um there is a specific provision within
the ndp policy hlu1
uh sorry the labor development plan
apologies uh the welford neighbourhood
plan
um policy hlu1 there are some
explanatory text
which acknowledges that welford at the
time of that
plan were already over their figure at
that point um
and there was a provision whereby on
there would still be suitable
development
and i'll call it verbatim now further
development during the planned period
should therefore take the form of
small-scale wind-filled windfall
development
on infill and redevelopment sites within
the village boundary
um this development meets in our
consideration all of those
mitigating factors sorry cancer adam do
carry on no no it's fine thank you
uh and the other one um was in relation
to
the lack of a response from seven trump
water as that seems to be quite a
concern for the war member
um was there can you elaborate on why
there
wasn't a response or did you have
anything at all i can't i'm afraid it's
a separate body i did obviously consult
them
um in the in the conversation period um
and up to dates up to this evening
there's no response from them um i can't
speak on their behalf i'm afraid um
as to why they haven't but i've detailed
in their agenda packs
we've obviously covered off flooding and
drainage
um we are in flood zone one the lowest
of the three categories
um the applicants in their submissions
provided everything that was mandatory
for them to provide
and we are satisfied that there is this
is in terms of flooding
and sewerage is an acceptable scheme
that's been reflected in our assessment
i think
i would perhaps add in that context that
the
um the development of this scale it's
not entirely unusual for seven trend to
to not involve themselves and
additionally for
development of this scale the
infrastructure requirements of the
development
are met by the community infrastructure
levy
which the case officer has also detailed
the charge which would be levied for
for this sort of development thank you
very much both councilman mills i think
you had a question
yes thanks richard stuart um the parish
council
um on the objections was bulk and mass
um the the house is opposite
um is it is it is it a lot higher than
the
houses opposite do you know or not i
mean
um they are approximately the same
height
as the dwellings across the ones we're
looking at on your screen right now for
example
yeah not for these uh bungalows you can
see here well they're the only
they're going out there they're modest
bungalows but the property is
immediately opposite
and the applicants in addition to uh
that submission plan there is another
plan on the application file provided by
the applicant which gives a wider
setting if you like of how these houses
sit in the wider street scene
and we're satisfied it is commensurate
with the
wider built form of the immediate
properties around it
thanks stuart thank you thank you very
much both councillor crump
it might be slightly tenuous and it is
to do with housing numbers and we're on
points of clarification
i've got a slight concern about the
discrepancy between the numbers
not for this particular application per
se but in overall terms
because if we're looking at the five
year house and none supply
and our numbers are not looking as good
as they should be
we need to make sure we've got as many
as possible with uh
to make sure we are achieving the five
year housing month supply
so it might not be relevant for this
application
it might be a conversation out elsewhere
i'm just looking for some
reassurance really and whether it has to
be taken outside i'm
i'm more than happy to deal with that as
well yeah i'm happy to talk to that
councillor crump
in in terms of our housing completions
and commitments
the um development management side of
the planning
authority works with planning policy who
do an
annual statement on both our five-year
housing land supply
and how many buildings dwellings have
been built and committed
during the following previous year um
inevitably there is a lag between that
and
any point a particular decision might be
made
that is entirely typical i think what's
important
is that our planning policy team follow
best practice in respect of
their annual monitoring of housing
commitments and delivery
and that they publish that and it is
therefore
transparent and available for for public
scrutiny
that's the document to which the case
officer has referred to
in his um in the agenda pack before you
it does confirm that uh welford has
um provided 131
um dwellings
total during the planned period that's
comprised briefly of 114 dwellings that
have been built
and 17 further commitments and that's
as of a measurement date of the 31st of
march 2020
so there is scope therefore for further
commitments to have been made since the
31st of march 2020 that aren't
comprised within that number um what we
would say is
that the overall intention of the
assessment within the gender pack
remains true
even if that number is 140 as might be
the case uh
put forward by the parish council the
case officers assessment remains the
same
and their recommendation would remain
the same because in our view the
sustainability impact of two additional
dwellings
in this location is is not so
significant as to warren a refusal
and because within um policy cs16 of the
core strategy
it's very clear that the numbers within
there are
not outright limits inspectors have held
that they are not outright limits
and lastly because of the adoption of
the nbp
which provides a specific policy that
recognizes that there has been
something of an over provision of new
dwellings but still allows for further
dwellings to be permitted on infill
plots as a windfall
and we felt this complies with that
that's the reason why we find in favor
of
a recommendation of approval at this
stage
if i may i also add up to that as well
please do straight thank you my senior
colleagues obviously addressed all the
scene
correctly all the same strategic points
of view if i can just zero on briefly on
the site specific element
um this is the third application of this
type on this site
um one consistent thread the principle
of development which obviously the
housing numbers relate to have been
deemed acceptable all the way through so
the principal development has not been
contested moreover the first one that
was refused went to
appeal inspectorate um the inspector
agreed with our assessment that the
principal was otherwise acceptable but
endorsed our
previous refusal on design grounds so
the principal
and housing numbers thereof haven't
really been contested over these
two previous applications and before you
tonight that's very helpful thank you
council crap if you've got to follow up
yeah i think what i was trying to make
was i wasn't had the particular
concerns around the numbers on this
application it was just a general one to
make sure
we were following best practice we were
accountable and we could
you know demonstrate our our five year
housing nun supply
uh successfully and transparently so uh
it was
just making sure we we're dotting the
eyes and crossing the t's
and i accept there will be some time lag
etc you know between though and
uh going back to march 2020 so i was
just making sure
so certainly i can i can speak to that
we we certainly are following
best practice um we have a five-year
housing land supply
in excess of seven years at the current
point and that's a supply which has been
um through appeal you know that has been
recently or
reasonably recently challenged at appeal
and inspectors have
happily accepted that the local planning
authority has a robust housing land
supply
thank you everyone cancer mills i think
you had another question yeah thanks
richard
the i can i see that the um the
reduction in height
has been it's a couple of times it's
been reduced um
is the looking at that is the width
being increased
but you know is the footprint larger
thank you chairman uh thank you
councillor um yes the
uh the overall aesthetic and design has
been changed all the way through the
height has been lowered
um by just over a meter from the first
scheme but before you
uh the sort of gray dotted line there
the whole design has changed as well the
whole aesthetic it was a more modern
uh proposal in the first application uh
that went then
and changed in both uh design and
footing the overall
bulk has been reduced uh the floor space
on this scheme
is uh less than the previous refusal as
well
uh the very first proposal also had a
car port separately a detached car
brought to the front that's no longer
on the table so the the bulk uh
built form has been reduced um
incrementally on each occasion
marvelous if there are no other
questions from our panel i have
one no okay so i think this is probably
for you david rather than anyone else
tier seven release site allocations plan
please can you give us a very
brief understanding of what that means
and why
uh i have to say i'm not overly familiar
with
the tiers within the site allocations
plan
um however i have a reason for that
that's because the site allocation plan
is a plan which is afforded very limited
way within the decision making
process at the current time um i think
it was mentioned that it's currently out
consultation on preferred options
it's not there for a document to which
um policies are within it that we could
afford any weight in decision making on
this case i thought you might say that
but it's helpful to have that
understanding
thank you very much okay given there are
no more hands or questions for points of
clarification let's move into the debate
who would like to kick us off councillor
jennings
okay well first of all um the applicants
has had extensive liaison with the
officers
they've reduced the bridge height by a
meter
ndp policy hlu1 allows small
scale windfall development on infill
sites
it's outside the conservation area all
houses opposite is two stories
so i don't see a bulk of massing problem
here
it's in flood zone one don't see a
problem there
i'm very happy to propose that we go
along with the officer's recommendations
and would like to propose that we grant
this application
thank you very much jennings councillor
kendall next please
thank you i think council general has
said everything for me that i can't find
any material grounds to go against this
one so i'm more than happy to second his
proposal
fabulous thank you very much council
curtis please thank you chair
um i do have a few concerns about this
um the variance in numbers
between parish and the offices does seem
significant and i wonder
at what point it would actually have a
material impact
on the officer's recommendation
um a couple of points from council
pertiguella
the infrastructure does appear to be
under strain
um and she outlined very eloquently the
problems of
sewage flooding so although the site
itself
may not be prone to flood i think there
is a wider
concern there
do these properties properties meet
local housing need
and i just as a further comment given
that welford has clearly exceeded its
housing numbers
do you really want to see every
available space green space
built on especially again listening to
councillor pair together's comments on
diversity and although
i understand that this may be permitted
surely there has to be some limit to the
number of houses
even built on small plots like this so
i just have some reservations about this
thank you chair
understood thank you council adam
thank you chair um i i can see that it
is generally
um an appropriate sized uh development
from the work that the the developers
have done with the
planning officers and i saw welcome that
um
but i the numbers is a sticking point
that i've had an issue with
on previous applications and i have
actually had applications within my ward
that have been refused on the grounds of
over development of
the the the settlements um
that haven't been successfully appealed
so i know that there are there are cases
where that has happened
now i i appreciate there is not an upper
limit but i think
saying that and using that as a
justification when the numbers are
potentially so excessive to be
over 100 over what what the core
strategy
um suggests it goes on to essentially
put that that clause in the core
strategy is is
superfluous um which i find very
troubling
i think the the the thing that's
standing out to me is that it is a
core strategy that is there for the
district
to have a strategic input into where we
put our housing
and the fact that the rolling land
supply
requirement has been used to
to refuse development elsewhere
uh demonstrates that they are at odds
and and effectively there is
scope within that for us as a committee
to
look at those numbers on a case-by-case
basis and say that this isn't acceptable
within that strategic look
i think that's the case here based on
the numbers that
we are seeing um
and i think that plays into the aspects
of infrastructure and all other aspects
of the site um because i'm concerned
that if we build on every patch of green
now
after 30 30 what uh 2031 there won't be
any more patches of green to build on
and we'll end up with much more bolt-ons
so although i think the two houses might
well fit as infill
uh the numbers are a pinch point for me
and so i'd actually propose
um to refuse the application on that
ground so cs16
um being uh holding significant weight
over the other of bearing
characteristics
thank you okay thank you very much
anyone else wants to come in cancer
crump
yeah also you know i fully sympathize i
obviously i know counts the um adam's
ward
and and my uh ward is taking
uh uh thousands of houses
um and i'm not exaggerating we're into
the thousands where
uh well we've had excessive um
numbers so i fully sympathize with that
but i've
got a slight concern obviously are we
saying that
because we've received a significant
number over the
um the 84 will we not be
allowing any more houses in welford
um we've got the on page 29 further
development during the plan should
therefore take the form of
small scale winford on infill and
redevelopment sites and i think this is
what it falls into
um so i will be supporting
the proposal by councillor jennings yeah
i have
much sympathy i yeah obviously i've
noticed the concerns about
the infrastructure but we've got nothing
from
from the southern trent to say this
would cause any significant extra harm
to that
so i will go with the officer's
recommendation on this one
thank you very much councillor crump
with no other hands available i will
just very quickly say
um or reiterate a few of the points that
you the council crumbles just made you
talk about numbers
um i think it's a very valid point that
the neighborhood development plan
clearly has a statement in it which has
been read out twice now i won't do it
again
that allows for infill plots which
in my belief this is we've also heard
from our case officer
that the numbers have been appealed
and not been a factor when it comes
including on this site
when it comes to an appeal we have to
bear that in mind when we're making
these decisions
um in terms of the infrastructure
absolutely sympathize with the
infrastructure i think the same issues
affect every village across our district
um we have a community infrastructure
levy there for a reason
uh we have just had a call for projects
uh i know snitchfield have put forward
one
in my patch i would suggest that all
members have a look at that and see what
options are available for infrastructure
but that i don't believe is a reason to
refuse this application so on balance
with all the evidence that's been
presented i am going to be going with
the officer's recommendation
with no further hands we have had a
proposal to grant from councillor
jennings it's been seconded by cancer
kendall so we will move to a vote
i will go first four oh actually i don't
need to do that do i i'm still
on live on teams modes i'm so sorry
so for those in favor of grant please
would you show us your little pink uh
slips not six jam thank you on those
against
one chair and those abstaining
one marvelous thank you very much
therefore committee resolves to grant
application twenty one zero zero five
zero zero full
lander jason's work field in middle is
close welford
okay we do need now to call uh
our next uh he's already here look at
that well prepared
we will just take a quick one minute
while we have a changeover of offices
and then we will carry on
so just one minute
okay thank you very much joe welcome uh
this evening um
so we will move straight to that your
next application or your first
application which is 21
0 0 0 5 8 out that is
amber cut school lane in prize marston
joe whenever you're ready over to you
thank you chair the site is located
within physical confines of priors
mastering as indicated by the black dock
for you the application is seeking
planning permission for the erection of
a two-story dwelling
to the rear of the dwelling house known
as ambercut
this application has been submitted as
outline application
however as detailed in the submitted
planning application form
all matters are to be considered part of
this application except landscaping
if permitted landscaping will be
detailed in the future reserve matters
application
the site is a mix of residential
dwellings to the south east and west
and easy to north across the public
footpath is priors marston primary
school
public footpath and a designated village
amenity space adjoins the curtlings of
the wellington north and east
respectfully the site is also contained
with the prize mastering conservation
area
just to give you some contact public
footpath the adjacent
to the site site area this is enclosed
by dwellings on all sides
including this piece of area here and
this is a problem from us
primary school and that is the church
this is a closer for the site so it
gives you more existing
um indication of undercutting his uh
development footprint
the site is present in residential
garden land for
garden land for a two-story wedding with
a single story elements and extensions
known as amber cut the dwelling if
permitted will we set
two-point meters to ridge with an
l-shaped layout
the dwelling will be constricted out of
horton ironstone and natural state very
finished with red brick chimneys the
dwelling is also proposing a rear garden
area circuit 190 square meters
and a front driveway with four parking
spaces a small garden area
this equates to approximately 50 square
meters as indicated in the plum
for you
these are the elevational drawings so it
gives you a good indication of how the
dwelling will be laid out and the stone
type and so forth i've already expressed
floor plans feedback during dwelling and
the l-shaped layout
and this is more for the development
context
this is amica itself and the east wing
extensions
has been now built from the 2016
commission which is referenced in the
report
this is the actual application site so
this is a rear garden area where the
dwelling would be
sighted if permitted and this is the
rear elevation of amica
this gives you a more indication of the
rear elevation of amca including
the east wing extension
this is a street scene so you can see
school lane
advocates here is the white horn the
dwelling and the neighboring properties
clean up school lane this is name and
dwelling
across the road as indicating the red
arrow
so it gives you a context of some of the
dwellings and nif city of site
this is a street scene for the daring
school lane so to the
left of the dwelling on principal
elevation and looking
down the street and having properties
and that is it in consideration the
area's development plan national policy
and guidance as well as the relevant
statutory consultations
the officer of recommendation is on
planning balance approval subject to the
recommended conditions
as set on the office report and the
subsequent section 106 agreement
as you'll see in the update sheet there
has been some updates in respect to the
section 106
and given that the section 106 has not
yet been assigned works have commenced
in the 2016 commission a fur
assessment was undertaken on the impact
of the neighboring meetings
which it would still determine the
application of courseworld standards and
guidelines
thank you thank you very much we'll move
straight to our first speaker who is
counselor john
franklin from prize martin parish
council good evening and welcome come on
forward
pleasure again if you wouldn't mind
quickly anti-backing your hands
um the button in the middle will turn
your microphone on
and you will have three minutes with 30
second warning make yourself comfortable
when you're ready please do start
a button in the middle yes please it
should turn red there you go
good evening thank you the contention
that we have on this
development that it is an over
development of the site
it's a backland infill
and what is currently an attractive
looking cottage with
good gardens will become two fairly
cramped properties
with far less immunity space um
although the officer states that the
immunity space meets exceeds the uh
uh minimum requirements we believe it
would be cramped and out of keeping with
the surrounding environment
it's our view that the immunity space
guidelines
might well work for towns and cities and
major developments
it's not necessarily appropriate for
villages
and it's quite important to take note of
the surrounding environment
i'd just like to read you a extract from
the
inspectors findings on a recent case in
our village where we had a small plot of
land
admittedly smaller than this where his
findings
on the 9th of december read the national
planning policy framework
requires a harm to be weighed against
the public benefits of the proposal
the development would add to the housing
stock however a single unit would not
provide
only sorry the single unit would
provide only modest benefits that would
not outweigh the detriment
conservation area it's quite clear that
when you come to discussing villages the
amount of space around houses is
important it's part of the character of
the village
and i think that's where our biggest
concern is
um moving on to other issues if you like
um as far as planning is concerned it is
not a self-build
is not being built for a resident um it
does not meet a housing need
it's a further erosion of the green
space
it is detrimental to the environment and
visual immunity
and is not in keeping with the general
appearance of the village
now i know that those are minor issues
for us the
big issue is what is the
appropriate space around around a house
in the village
and this is where we i think we differ
from the planning officer
okay thank you very much members do you
have any questions for our counselor
please
lots of pensive looks no in that case
counselor thank you very much for your
contribution
um if you wouldn't mind very quickly
running an anti-bank wipe over there's a
bin next year i should have mentioned
this earlier there is a bin there for
everyone to throw them in
you don't have to take them
thank you very much thank you
one for stuff thank you very much
councillor franklin okay our next
speaker
is council rock uh council rob if you
could put your do you need to wear a
mask or
you've got a dispensation
we're technically we're supposed to wear
them when we're moving between chairs
i'm sorry to be a pain i i wouldn't have
a problem with it but i think it's
legislation so we should obey
okay so you have less than one minute
[Laughter]
lovely to see you here um you as you
know we'll have five minutes whenever
you are ready
uh please do start and we'll give you a
30 second warning for your time is that
thank you very much indeed don't forget
to turn your microphone on as well
please
lovely well good evening everybody and
uh
what an interesting situation we have
here for after what 18 months or
something
um well uh i just got a comment on what
the parish council said i mean i've got
quite a lot of sympathy about the minima
that they talk about
immunity land around uh sites in prize
marston
uh the bronze most very pretty little
village
obviously you can only see a snapshot
this very congested space was commented
on
on the planning appeal that the parish
council had mentioned
um about constricting it and i've
discussed that with
with the planning office on several
occasions but that's not really my
principal concern my principal concern
is what what you may approve tonight
and that's the interaction between the
existing building
on the front there shown in grey and the
one at the back
now i withdrew my objection on the basis
that it said in the original report
that the permission to extend that
building was going to be rescinded
because you couldn't actually get to the
back of this building
with the permission that they've got
this this one that's number
something sixteen fourteen hundred uh
that permission export extensions on
both the east and the west sides of that
um they haven't built the one
to the west but they have built the one
to the east
and they've built it in such a way not
in accordance with the plan
so we have a complicated situation which
i think
the officers uh fully prepared to
concede
where what is on the on the ground
is not been built according to the
approved plans
it interferes with the vision supplies
and
something is going to have to happen to
make this application valid
uh and to be able to be built out so
the office has done done his best i
i'll congratulate him in
trying to explain what is a highly
complicated situation on this update
sheet
but we have to be very careful about i
think what we're approving here
my my recommendation would be this
application is deferred until we sort
out what's being built
effectively we've got a scheme for two
dwellings here one of which has not been
built properly
and the other one is backland
development which you can't properly
access
because of the uh the highways issue
because
what has been built there is not as it's
shown on there and indeed is not
what was shown on the approved
permission so i
i think that's the element that you
should be exploring
uh i'll just add one other item i think
if you if you do decide to approve this
tonight i would suggest another
condition which is a levels condition
um because there's a a visual
interaction between
the uh this new house and the school
which is the heritage building the back
it's not listed
it is in the conservations its own but i
wouldn't want the building
height to effectively go up because of
the landlord so we start with the levels
condition
but otherwise i'm very uncomfortable
about what we've got what we're going to
approve compared with what we've got
here and i know these reinforcement
issues
but that really just wants sorting out
before this
this build went forward thank you
chairman and i do apologize for moving
without the mask
no problem at all thank you very much
council rock um i'm going to start
questions
if i may uh specifically about the
what's been built there and the
enforcement what have you we obviously
have no impact over enforcement at this
committee
we need to let that run its course um
you'll note
i think you probably have the agenda
back in front of you on page 47
that uh the recommendation is subject to
the completion of a legal agreement in
s106 specifically
uh that the extent permission is to be
rescinded and failing that the
permission will be refused
that is my reading of that are you
comfortable that that covers the issues
you've got
or um officers have i misinterpreted
that i think chair there is something in
the update sheet
that adds a little nuance to that
um forgive me i haven't seen this yet
yes apologies chair
the the update she adds a little nuance
um it says
that the permission will effectively be
cancelled out insofar as it relates to
the
westward rejection approved
you're still with that you're still
unhappy is that
a fair fair thing so uh that's correct
chairman i'm i'm
i'm not happy about some of the
interaction on the on the
east eastern end as well because of the
interaction and i think
it's very unclear uh i i was very happy
with it being rescinded
and starting again and seeing uh a
better application
uh tidied up on the front but uh it
i was very happy with the report which
is why i withdrew my objection
but i i think there's a lot of confusion
here i i think you might be right
um now that i have that and i've read it
i understand your position thank you
um councillors do we have any questions
for our ward member
no okay in that case council rock thank
you very much once again if you could
remask and give the table a quick wipe
um
and we will carry on while you're doing
that if we may
don't forget to wipe the table please
[Laughter]
members do we have any points of
clarification for the officers
counselor adam thanks um just
something that counselor rock mentioned
in regards to highways
um and the
the external permission which has
been built apparently incorrectly um
was their assessment based on the
current construction as it is
on site or is it based on the permission
that is extent
uh there's a few elements to that
character so let me
try and make it as clear as i possibly
can d
let me go to the photo to the east wing
so that's what's been built on the east
wing and this is the issues
that's been raised when the application
was originally submitted
um this is wing wasn't built though
fundamentally was there was no east wing
at all so highways have has done their
assessment
when it was originally submitted on the
basis that east wing wasn't there
what you can see here is highways have
done the assessment on the extent
permission
which shows that visibility displays can
be achieved
now they have also requested the
conditions for the visibility display to
be
maintained throughout and on top of that
if the plans if that each wing is built
not in accordance with the approved
plans
which it looks like i could well be the
possibility
it is an enforcement issue and that
would have to be rendered
correctly the condition could never be
met
as if these visibility plays can't be
achieved
i hope that makes sense
thanks jim okay does anyone else have
any points of clarification
counselor jennings the parish of
uh raised this issue about the
appropriate size of the garden amenity
land
does this meet um our criteria
it certainly meets it it's 109 square
meters
um that isn't the only point of
assessment when doing this though
uh just for clarification points for
chad's mind i'll raise some additional
slides
um because the paris have raised the
issue regarding the appeals statement so
we've done that assessment as well
so this is the appeal that they are
referring to
so you can see the open location plan
there
and the site area is about there and you
can see the characters of the area
of the open nature now the site appeal
in the character area
has been duly assessed here so this is
the uppercase site appreciate trees are
inside
but on my recommendation you can see it
is
a lot more dense around that area of the
village and for that reason
as well as the excess and garden area i
came to the occlusion that it was
in keeping with the character of the
area and the conservation area
any further points of clarification no
in that case let's go to debate who
would like to kick us off
councillor mills yes yes
uh thanks mr chairman um um
i i can't say i like the look of this i
mean i when i
saw the site and saw that extension on
the front crumbs that looks
pretty awful and then i know it's got
nothing to do with it there's a
house further down the road a brand new
one that looks
pretty awful and i thought fitting
something around
in the back garden i it to me
it didn't sit right um with me um
i i just don't like the look of the
whole area
um and
is it is it over development of the site
i mean joe was saying
uh it fits in quite well he's got
land right somebody's is over
development with the site
um just dropped something in here the
last time i
visited um uh village um
when i saw lord spencer but me he didn't
take me for a drink there
but um um i
i i don't like this um
site mr chairman i'm gonna think about
good planning reason why i
i should object so uh at the moment i
would object to it mr chairman
thank you thank you very much mills
we'll give you a couple of minutes to
think about reasons
who else would like to speak outside
jennings next please
councillor jennings sorry to interrupt
you microphone thank you
my apologies the main parish issue seems
to be the appropriate size of the garden
the minty land
and the officers made it quite clear
that that isn't an issue i mean
there are there seem to be extensive
conditions
attached to this
application which seemed like a very
good idea
again it seems we have another infill
plot
um whether the house
amber coat whether they've done their
extension
right or wrong is is not really relevant
to this particular
planning application because we're
talking about a planning application
behind it um so to me
that's irrelevant um
and i can see no material plain reason
to go against the officer's
recommendations so
when when it comes to which i'll be i'm
quite happy to actually propose
to regrant planning on this
thank you very much casa jennings
councillor adam next please
thank you um i i do have some concerns
over the points made by the mood
member particularly in regard to
the highways consultation if they made
their consultation response prior to the
um the extant permissions
construction being made i'm i'm
struggling to see how that can be
validated um particularly when
visibility displays are a condition
being recommended by the officer um
i don't necessarily think that's reason
to to
oppose it in terms of planning grounds
but i do consider
the suggestion by the war member to
defer this application
until a reassessment by highways could
be made
so that we can be sure of what
is achievable on site because although
it is a
distinct site in and of itself the
the other buildings around it do have an
impact on on any planning permission
um and so i'd actually propose that we
make that deferral so that we can have
reassessment
and also we may be that um our
enforcement team may have
achieved something in that time as well
not that material to our decision here
okay thank you very much council adam uh
i've got councillor candle next
kendall it's okay that way um thank you
chair
um i think council jennings has put it
into words again tonight
he's sneaking my notes but he's fast
quicker witted than i am
um i'm not concerned about enforcement i
think that is an issue somewhere else
not here
um the immunity space it yeah we'd all
like to have more immunity space
i know i would but we do have a set
criteria for that and
i think well this is within those those
requirements so i can't see that as a
strong reason for refusal is it over
development
i don't i don't think this is uh i'm
satisfied the extent permission
issues are going to be solved i think
you've answered all the questions there
really well we've got no objection
county highways i'm happy to second your
proposal that we grant this application
thank you very much councillor kendall
councillor curtis next please
thank you chair um i'm
just more in agreement with with
councillor adam here i i think
deferring to get the additional
information from highways
would be a better course at this stage
there's some great deal of confusion
over this application um if we were
to grant i would like us to take into
account um
council rock's concerns over a levels
condition being
added to this as well
explain to me exactly what we want in
terms of the levels condition
well i i think i i'd probably pretend to
defer to castle rock on this but if he
feels that the
um height of the building could i
believe
is it um imposed on the
school nearby
okay i think um before we get too caught
up on that because this this is
a somewhat confusing application as i
have shown myself
and i apologize to both of our planning
officers you did say during your
opening speech about the um the
condition so i forgive me for that
um i don't want to get too far into that
when we have a proposal to
grant if that fails then we can then
start to discuss
further what you've just proposed now i
think that's the right way to go about
this
so we have a proposal it has been
seconded
the proposal is to grant in line with
the office recommendation including the
update sheet
um could we please have a show of hands
for those in favor of grant
that's root five jai thank you
so therefore committee resolves to grant
application twenty one
zero zero zero five eight out uh that is
america's
school lane in price marston thank you
very much everybody we will now move to
our final application of the evening
uh which is application reference twenty
zero three five four nine ful at sun
barn farm in significant fields our
plans come together
so that was obviously with all the
conditions which
um the officer had recommended yes it's
in line with the officer recommendations
and the update sheet so yeah yes
that's exactly as set out yeah
forgive me joe it's over to you
thanks jeff the site is located at
san barn farm which is situated
approximately 500 meters to the
northwest of hampton lucie
as indicated by the black doctor for you
sambar farm is attached farmhouse for
the main part being 17th century with a
latter part probably being around 19th
century
and his grade 2 listed building is
timber frame with brick infield on brick
print
and old tile roof tiles
so this gives you some uh context of the
site sandville
farm uh existing farm houses
neighborhood road and this is the
residence garden area the site is
approximately
the proposed development that i'll go
into is going to be approximately
located in this vicinity
this application seats for the erection
of a largely attached oat frame swimming
pool building on the southwest boundary
of the garden
as indicated by the plum for you
the size of the pros building is 7.5
meters wide
9.2 meters long with a ridge height of
4.8 meters
and with other basement areas include a
treatment room sauna
toilet plant room and storage areas
this is the grade 2 listed building the
sand uh sunburned farmhouse
uh also please take note of the arrow so
it gives you a good indication where the
solid photos go so you can see where
we're facing
this is obviously still a great two bar
i know it's coming down around the
corner
the proposal involved building will be
roughly in that area
further context swim pool to building
there green house this is
the elevation somewhere farmers
looking back up because you can take
context for the greenhouse which
shows the whole garden area
once again gives you better views of the
garden area and the residential meeting
space
gives you a context of what's in the
elevations australian context
and that's the end of presentation
thank you very much joe um okay let's
move to our first speaker
casa cara matthews good evening from
hampton parish council
lucy crash council
it's a councilman i think you've you
know the drill uh three minutes we'll
give you a 30 second warning towards the
end um
whenever you are ready and you've made
yourself comfortable do feel free to
start
hi everybody i'm going to be wonderfully
brief you'll be pleased to hear
um just to say that the parish council
looked this application up to the site
looked to the planning grounds
and we didn't really have any problems
with it um
there's no public views no footpath
no views in the footpath that will be
impeded no ecology
issues no residential immunity issues
um and we don't really agree that
um the proposal would cause visual harm
to the character and distinctiveness of
the
of of the host dwelling we're very keen
the parish council to preserve what
we've got in the way of
listed buildings we're surrounded by
them but we really did not feel that
this was
um this one should be refused um so
that's all i've got to say
that's right that was very brief thank
you very much thank you for your
patience for
waiting this long uh before you go
anywhere do we have any questions for
the parish council
no okay very brief uh if i could ask you
once again yeah remast give it a quick
one
yeah that'll be lovely thank you very
much
there's so much else to say was there
really
oh thank you so much
okay our final speakers of the evening
now we have two gentlemen
joel leeson and andrew i'm gonna
hopefully i'll pronounce this right well
is that right
perfect um are you sharing the time
have you got an allocated split in terms
of time so a minute and a half minute
and a half is that right
two and a one okay uh so i'm assuming uh
you must be
andrew pyle is that correct who are you
going first
okay in that case if you want to make
your way up and joel if you would sit
there
we'll do a two minute timer and then
we'll do a one minute because we've only
got the one desk i'm afraid so
um yeah we've got to be mine for the
code rules
so we'll put two minutes on the clock
we'll give you a thirty second warning
before that
time's up if that's okay otherwise when
you're ready and comfortable
do feel free to start your microphone is
already on so you don't need to press
that
okay thank you chair as the applicant's
agent i should like to take this
opportunity to remind members
of the key issues relating to your
consideration of the proposals
you will be aware that this is a revised
proposal to that which you considered
your 7th october meeting last year
at that meeting you had no issues with
the design style adopted
which in reflecting that of an
agricultural building is not in congress
with its context
nor did you consider that the location
of the building would impact on the
setting of the house
your only concerns were in relation to
the relative size of the building
compliance with the council's climate
change policies
and its potential impact on adjoining
trees and each of these issues has now
been suitably addressed
in terms of its relative size your
office's report confirms that the
building's footprint has been reduced
it is also significantly smaller in
scale than the existing barn which lies
adjacent to the driveway
it's a full 42 meters from the main
living accommodation of the farmhouse
and 37 metres from the utility room
the photo montage clearly demonstrates
that the proposed building would not
represent a dominant feature
and as there is very limited
intervisibility between the pool house
and
firehouse would not compromise or cause
harm to the setting of the listed
building
as to the other concerns your office's
report now confirms that there is no
conflict with the council's climate
change policy
and that the building would not have a
harmful impact on the trees
in summary there is no evidence to
support the objections
raised by your officers no substance to
any of the alleged policy conflicts
and therefore no reasonable grounds on
which to base the recommended refusal
the applicants have addressed all the
concerns previously raised by members
and now seek support your support in
granting approval
can i just add that we did submit two
images for display
during the meeting which are the photos
bear with me and i will check just thank
you would you mind turning your
microphone off while we do that thanks
we don't appear to have received any can
do you know where they were sent
to
um
i'll tell you what if what we'll do is
we'll we'll go and check to see if we
can find them
while we have mr leeson do his minute if
that's okay and then we can bring them
back up then if we have found them
if that's all right indeed so one of
them
is perhaps part of what's already shown
on the um
display there it's one which is shows
the relative distance between the house
and the um that's right yeah so it's an
extract of that
the other one may not
it wasn't shown but it is a photo
montage which shows the proposed
building it's one of the left-hand
corners top left-hand corner if that
don't be enlarged
okay and then um it is a photo montage
which shows
the proposal institute so those are the
two images basically so if
given given we're seeing essentially the
images here yep um
are you satisfied that we have seen them
now if members are clear that
they they can interpret the photo
montages showing that i'm happy
members are you happy that you can
interpret that
if you want to make your way closer to
the screens if you can't make out the
photos and what have you
it'll save us having to go upstairs
happy everyone on my right hand side
you're all happy are you
everyone on my left you're all happy i
think that's a series of nods
before you go anywhere any questions
no in that case if you wouldn't mind
giving the desk a quick wipe and
read applying your mask that would be
great
and once we have done that mr leeson
will come forward
thank you very much mr well mr listen
thank you for your patience please do
come on forwards
i've got good news for you you have an
extra 15 seconds
it's the plywood managed to get in in
innocent time so you have one minute and
15 seconds
um we will start the clock whenever
you're ready so make yourself
comfortable and as soon as you're set if
you start
press the red button or the middle
button sorry and feel free to stop thank
you thank you
good evening committee and thank you for
your time firstly i want to apologize
for our previous application
it really wasn't clear in showing what
we wanted to achieve
but as a positive it did give us the
opportunity to get your feedback about
the principle of the application and the
location uh but you were clear on your
comments on on the size and and some
other points
as a result we've reduced the size of
the building uh we simplified the design
you'll be able to see as andrew
mentioned the the proposed building is
42 meters from our home
uh our neighbors are actually 28 meters
away from us so the building is further
away than our neighbors
there's a very substantial stand of
trees between the proposed building and
the house
so that in our opinion there is no
impact on the historical listed building
the sighting of the building is next to
a horse paddock a hen coupe
and a riding school so it's an
agricultural setting
uh the style of the building is also
agricultural and we feel it's very much
in keeping with south warwickshire uh
style of barns and buildings
we hope that you are able to approve our
updated application
and that we've taken on board and
reflected on the feedback we received at
the last application
perfect and thank you very much that's
just spot
on time members do we have any questions
mr listen
no okay thank you very much thank you
i think you know the drill now all right
uh points clarification for officers
members do we have any points of
clarification council mills first please
thanks richard um joe can you
can you indicate the size of the uh
the proposed um application to the size
of the house is it
um is it longer than the house or is it
i think the best way to do that is
probably like build-wise is to
look at the these two plans um
it's set out in the report what the size
is of this
building case officer so you can see
that's the square footage there which is
pretty much represented there which is
the
the square footage in comparison the
existing building
appreciates cut off and suddenly i don't
have another image to show you that
could put the two together what i could
show you is
that comparison so it is
a reasonably sized building compared to
that dwelling there but i couldn't give
you exact figures
between the two
sorry and how far away from the house
itself
i can do that and then i can zoom in on
that's good so it shows you definitively
what it is
so from there it's 42 meters the house
itself
and it is uh
37.5 meters to the utility room so you
too i'm just there because i appreciate
that's not very good
so yeah 14 meters so that's the extent
house there utility room
387.5
right and and there are there are no
public footpaths
no i sat out in the office report and
there is no
difference yeah okay thank you thank you
council curses please yeah joe could you
um just to help me visualize this more
clearly
could you bring up the aerial photo
again
and indicate on that where
the proposed building would be so yeah i
think
just so it is really clear the way you
do it is use the reference point of the
greenhouse
so if you can see the greenhouse and the
way it's positioned
because they've done very clearly
so it'll be basically coming down off
there and
i'll just move sorry do you apologize
coming down off there and within that
sort of boundary location
you can see because then that is a
square area as well
see that square field path gives you the
indication so it'll be
so it is in that area yeah
that's very helpful thank you very much
thank you okay any other members with
questions or points of clarification
no in that case let's move to debate who
would like to kick us
off councilman
thanks mr yeah um
so i jump i i i can't see problems
it's quite away from the house i don't
think it's it's overbearing on the house
it's my opinion
um there's no footpath nobody can see it
um
i don't think it's even tucked behind
trees there
um i i
i don't have a problem with it at the
moment mr chairman thank you
is that a proposal councillor mills yeah
i propose yeah thank you very much uh
who would like to go next councillor
adam please
i'm happy to second councilor mills um
proposal
i i can see why there is due concern and
it's sort of
holding on us to make sure that when
looking at listed assets that we do
give it due process but i think the
applicants have clearly listened to what
we've said and tried to be sympathetic
to that and even apologized to the
committee for previous applications i
think
that's you know seems very reasonable
and uh
so i'm happy okay thank you very much
um councillor fleming please i was just
going to say something very similar to
councillor adam the applicants realized
that
there were certain things that we
weren't happy with and
and they've gone away and addressed
those issues and come back with the uh
with a revised plan that i think is
takes into consideration
everything that was said before thank
you thank you very much
bear with me would anyone else like to
have any say
now council jennings okay
whilst i appreciate that the applicant
has gone away and
and looked at this again and come back
i'm still
um not 100 happy about the
actual size it's absolutely huge
swimming pool complex
so
i'm considering at the moment
okay thank you cancer kendall thanks i'm
similar again councilor jennings
um i'm on the fence very much i've got a
question though
in terms of um a condition
uh obviously we're
you're recommending refused uh in terms
of conditions would we be able to have
some sort of condition
regarding uh heavy landscaping screening
that go with this if we were minded to
grant
if you're a mindset i would recommend
putting a landscaping condition on
purely because it is in the open
countryside and you have got it next to
a grade two listed building which could
affect its setting
yeah and and in terms of that condition
could we go further
in in terms of maintaining and uh
retention
of that screening in perpetuity you
could it's certainly in the condition
standards is normally about five years
um i probably would have to ask david if
it
could do it beyond like it yeah i think
you probably could um
through condition require maintenance
for the duration of the development
okay because that would be crucial to my
thinking okay in that case um
yes i think i'm probably happy to grant
this one
thank you okay thank you very much um
i'm going to call
council jeffrey sorry i'm going to call
david jeffrey in a second but before i
do
i'm just going to ask our proposing our
seconder we do need to have a clear
reason why we think we can go against
the refusal
so reasons i guess reasons why you don't
think they apply
let me give you some assistance you have
already
you already talked about the distance
that it is away from the listed building
my understanding from what you said is
that provided there is an appropriate
landscaping scheme
um including the trees that are already
there uh
that you consider the uh proposed to be
far enough away
from the listed building for it not to
have an impact
is that a fair assessment that is a
perfect mr chairman
thank you very much cancer adam are you
happy or is there anything you want to
add
no very happy with that thank you
marvelous thank you very much in that
case
david you had a comment you'd like to
make and if you could also comment on
the reasons we've just given you
if you're happy or not yes chair thank
you
um just following on from a couple of
comments
uh i thought it would be pertinent to
bring to members attention
um the previous application um
which was refused for four reasons
um before members reach a conclusion
that
all of the matters uh raised in those
reasons for refusal have been addressed
um i think it was pertinent to note that
the first two reasons
of refusal um formulate the officers
reasons for refusal of this application
um the second two reasons which were
raised
um for the previous refusal was that the
application was not accompanied by an
assessment of the impact on trees that's
obviously not been
brought forward through the officer's
recommendation on this occasion
um and that the um
transition to a low carbon future hadn't
been addressed was the fourth reason
um on the reason for refusal last time
now as i say
members obviously veering towards a
conclusion that the
uh first two reason has reasons have
been addressed by the applicant it is
notable i think
that the reasons put forward by the
officer for refusal
are the same two reasons
so it was really just to draw that to
members attention before
they conclude their debate
i'm forgive me i i'm a bit rusty and i'm
getting a little confused
you're talking about two reasons for
refusal on the previous one
they're not on this one so the only two
reasons
are the first two which are laid out in
this report
correct
okay all right fine thank you
okay we've had a we've had a proposal
it's been seconded
and we've had a reason why uh
councillors
the proposer and the secondary uh
believe that we can go against officer
recommendation
you're satisfied that we have given
robust reasoning
i'm satisfied i've had a reason um the
reason
i've noted here is that the distance
away from the listed
building although there would be some
intervisibility could be mitigated
through appropriate landscaping and
through the imposition of conditions
which would
secure landscaping for the duration of
development
okay thank you
would you mind awfully joe if you could
list a conditions that you would apply
should we go with a grant please
so standard time limit three years plans
i would recommend material schedule
given the close nature to the heritage
um asset as well as the open nature of
the surrounding countryside climate
change checklist
uh wart butts which match with the
climate change checklist for downpipes
and as well as the recommended health
and soft landscaping
with special reference regarding
screening and the longevity of
the abuse
thank you very much counselor krump yeah
just starting on to the conditions i'll
know
just on about landscaping et cetera
it's mentioned in the report on page 55.
um
you have to be more explicit about the
tree protection
uh in accordance with bs 5837
colon 2012 which i'm fully familiar with
of course
um does that need to be uh specific
could we
i would recommend not i do know what
you're saying i'd say that more to be
with a note to be honest the reason
being is they have submitted
the or the say the word to apologize
they have submitted the um statement
showing that it shouldn't impact on any
trees and therefore the veterans should
adhere
uh we could put a condition on saying it
has to be in accordance with the
assessment and then the taken if you so
wish
do you so wish well i'd like to air on
the side of caution uh just to be on the
on the safe side um but i'm gonna see
it's it's to the proposers and seconders
i guess that need to respond to that are
you happy
you want to add that in no
okay we're going to move towards a vote
in a second because otherwise this is
going to get overly complicated
um any more for any more before we do
no okay in that case we have a proposal
to grant for the reasons that have been
set out the conditions we've just heard
um including the landscaping let's move
to a vote
could we please have a show of hands for
those in favor of granting
and those against and abstentions one ja
in that case committee therefore
resolves to grant an application twenty
zero three
five four nine ful sambar farm in
snitterfield that
with no urgent business concludes oh
bear with me
because we've made it
forgive me um clearly i am very rusty
because
i should have sought to propose and the
secondary for our first one which was
mackelberg green
so i'm going to propose that we delegate
to officers could i have a second it
please thank you very much counselor
kendall could i have a show of hands for
those in favor
you know that is unanimous uh thank you
very much forgive me it has been a tough
thing managing everything it's weird
being in person but it's
very good to see everyone anyway thank
you very much we will close the meeting